[Music]
without much further ado I'm gonna bring
our speaker and relay cough who is an
anthropologist at USC and is going to
talk to us tonight about how we became
unprepared big round of applause Fran so
first of all I want to thank Michael and
all the folks at the interval for not
only the invitation but the tremendous
work they do to organize to put together
to get the speakers into shape for the
presentation so there's a lot behind
what you guys see each time you come
here tonight um as I so I'm typically
used to lecturing to very tired
undergraduates as a professor and and I
I came to an event here at the start of
my blissful year at casbahs and saw that
in fact this was more of a you know
lively spoken word type of venue and I
really left at the chance to have
instead of having kind of bored students
with hangovers in the audience in the
morning to see an audience of people who
had come here voluntarily and had
cocktails in their hands I as I as I
spoke with Michael in preparation for
this talk about how did how to think
about what to present he reminded me
that these are fun lively events I
should think about something you know
relaxing enjoyable to talk about so I
decided to to focus on you know one
aspect of my work which is the
possibility of future catastrophes
nobody in all seriousness this the work
that's being done here at the interval
and the long now foundation on forms of
temporality on how to think about the
how to think about the unknown future is
really a propo for the kinds of things
I've been working on for the last few
years so I'm really delighted to have
the chance to share this with you okay
let me start so you've already you all
probably heard a statement something
along the lines of what you see
at the bottom here given typically by a
public official or or a specialist we're
overdue and we're underprepared it could
be for a number of different things a
mega earthquake a cybersecurity attack
crippling our life-sustaining
infrastructure a nuclear accident in
this case we have the Department of
Health and Human Services Secretary back
in 2005 saying we're not prepared for
the outbreak of a humanly transit
transmissible severe strain of pandemic
influenza so what do all of these
various kinds of potentially
catastrophic events have in common
first of all in most cases they have not
occurred or they're very rare
secondly their onset is foreseeable but
not predictable thirdly they're
potentially calamitous not only to
individual lives but also to economies
and to social order as I talked about
these kinds of events or at least the
way we we we prepare for these kinds of
events I'm not going to try to get you
to be more worried about them even if
perhaps we should be and I'm not going
to advise you on how we can become more
prepared rather what I want to do is
pose the question of how we came to
think about the future in this
particular way the argument I want to
make is that we have a range of we have
a range of available ways to think about
and act on the future which particular
threats we focus on and how we approach
how we approach them hinges on the tools
that we use to make the future available
to us in the present as Michael
mentioned I'm an anthropologist and my
particular area of specialization is the
Anthropology of knowledge so I'm
interested not so much in the public
imagination of future catastrophes or in
mass cultural representations or rather
in often hidden or secret ways that
experts and authorities plan for a
future disaster
by experts here I mean actors who have a
capacity to make authorized truth claims
based on culturally sanctioned expertise
on the left here is an image from the
1960s of a prestigious think-tank the
RAND Corporation that was composed of
experts from fields like mathematics
political science and economics and they
were typically charged with planning for
the future the future of war but other
kinds of futures as well one of the most
famous members of the RAND Corporation
was the the man here on the right hand
side Herman Kahn he was a mathematician
who eventually became famous for
promoting the t'nuk the technique of
scenario based planning some of some of
you may have heard of him I'll return to
him toward the end of the talk but what
I want to emphasize but the moment is
just that these are prestigious figures
who have the capacity to tell us
something about what the future holds so
let me just preview the argument that I
want to make in the talk basically that
during the period of the heyday of the
RAND Corporation and a little bit before
hand a set of techniques and concepts
were developed initially for dealing
with a threat of nuclear war and that
these techniques and calm concepts were
gradually extended and applied to a
range of other kinds of disasters from
natural disasters to potential terrorist
attacks eventually to pandemics and that
you can think of these techniques
together as a really systematic way of
approaching the future so what do I mean
by tools for thinking about the future
I'll just give you a few examples but I
already mentioned scenario based
exercises these help us to imaginatively
enact a dangerous future and also to
generate knowledge about our current
vulnerabilities in relationship to that
future another technique is the Sentinel
device these are devices that track the
possible onset of a future catastrophic
catastrophic event and they trigger
pre-planned responses to that event
a third example of a technique of
preparedness stockpiles of essential
supplies these this is one of the
signature methods of preparing for a
disaster that could strike at any time
the images here are all preparedness for
public health disasters which is the
area that I've mainly worked on in the
last few years but they're really
generic techniques that apply to a range
of possible events so again if you put
these elements together you have a
preparedness system that not only
describes possible future occurrences
but actually constitutes occurrences as
events of a certain kind I'll explain
what I mean by that later okay stepping
back for a second I'll put on my kind of
classical anthropological hat and say
most societies historically and
cross-culturally have some kind of
officially sanctioned authority figures
who have some kind of special access to
what the future may hold this image is
from a very old and widespread way of
dealing with an unknown and perilous
future divination and prophecy it's an
image of the Oracle of Delphi who was
often consulted by leaders in ancient
Greece when they had to make major
decisions such as whether to go to war
the Oracle of Delphi like other seers
had a capacity to interpret signs of a
predetermined future and these signs
were otherwise unintelligible to the
rest of us of course as Oedipus proved
just because you've been told what your
future holds does not mean you're going
to be able to avoid it but the key point
for our purposes here is that from the
perspective of divination and prophecy
key future events are foreordained it's
just that we don't have access to to
knowledge about them but it's fair to
say that Oracle's and prophets are not
the culturally dominant authorities we
have concerning the future today it's
hard for example to find a class in
divination at most current universities
um and this is at least in part because
modern time is famously open-ended the
future is not yet determined we tend to
believe that our decisions in the
present will shape what the future is
going to become
um but we do have tools for thinking
about how our present actions may relate
to and shape this uncertain future let
me start with an example that I think is
highly significant in many areas of
contemporary life I'm gonna call this an
actuarial device I'll explain why so
obviously it's a table but it's also a
device and it assembles a large amount
of data about the historical occurrence
of certain kinds of events and it uses
this data to find regularities or
patterns that can tell us about what is
likely to happen next this kind of
device this sort of table was originally
invented in the 17th century by English
political economists these were the
earliest scientists who tried to apply
economic thought to the policy as a
whole people like John Grant and William
petty who's quoted here put together
what had been very scattered and
heterogeneous bits of information on
deaths births illnesses and they found
something striking when they assembled
these all into a table and ordered them
according to years and I found something
that's reasons that will become obvious
very clear to us today but was not known
at the time even though at the register
of individual or family experience a
given birth or death is a unique
singular contingent event if you map
these collectively this show really
impressive regularities if you look at
the entire population you see this
roughly the same number of births and
deaths happening every year in a given
place and then interesting things were
found by a pointer if you look over on
the right-hand side things you know it's
very constant that and we all know this
now there's more males born than females
each year but it wasn't known until you
assemble all this knowledge together so
what was gradually being discovered that
was that while the future is open-ended
it's not determined one can roughly
forecast that it will be somewhat like
the past at least in these respects and
knowledge of these kinds of patterns was
critical for the insurance industry just
merging at that time you can only begin
to have an idea of what to charge for
accident insurance or life insurance or
if you have some sense of how likely is
given these events are to happen in a
given year okay
skipping had a couple of centuries with
the cons with the consolidation of the
modern nation-state in Europe in the
18th and 19th century you see these
kinds of devices this form of
calculation becomes central to
government policies in fields like
Public Health the term statistics arose
at this time as many of you will know it
means originally the science of the
state and it comes from the period when
these European countries established
bureaucratic agencies like Census
Bureau's whose task was to track life
events in the population such as births
death illness rates of suicide and so on
and again it was found that these showed
regularities and that if the state
policies could actually affect these
rights so they kind of the early origins
of what we now know as the welfare state
in this quotation from this British
social reformer William Farr
he's noting that again we can't say
exactly what's going to happen to any
given individual born in the year 1841
when he's writing but there are these
regularities like lifespan that allow us
to make some fairly accurate demographic
predictions given the number of people
born in Europe as a whole in 1841 he
says we can surmise roughly how many are
still going to be alive 80 years later
in 1921 moreover if you look at this
chart carefully far is introducing
another discovery that's quite important
for our story it turns out that life
expectancy varies by place if you're
born in the rural southern relatively
wealthy area of Surrey in England your
life is going to be longer than if
you're born in one of the urban areas
industrializing at the time like London
and Liverpool as you can see from the
chart it's particularly perilous to be
an infant in Liverpool
so this kind of actuarial knowledge
these tables make it possible to
calculate individual race they sorry
individual risk based on social
characteristics such as age sex location
and so on this image which you see also
over here thanks to auto is what William
Farr the same British social social
reformer are called by ometer measure a
device to measure life in particular
here what what this device measured was
the risk of contracting cholera in one
of the major epidemics that hit London
in 1832 and according to far your risk
of contracting cholera if he lived in
London in 1832 hinged on how high in the
city you live so it's a very visual
graphic representation of risk the
higher you are the lower your risk is
according to far based on his
statistical calculations of contracting
cholera now he thought that this
actually demonstrated his theory of the
cause of cholera people didn't yet know
that cholera was a bacteria that was
transmitted via things like exposure to
sewage so he saw that cholera travel
through the air for the miasma and they
who were less likely to contact to come
to contact with this air the higher you
were London so if you can you can see
these numbers if you're living at 300
feet only 7 out of every 10,000 people
living at that that altitude died of
cholera and the epidemic but you know if
you're down in the neighborhood of 40 40
50 sorry 40 30 20 feet your risk of
contracting it is much higher so we now
know that far was wrong in his theory of
disease con causation but the method he
was developing of tracking risk and then
targeting public health interventions
based on this knowledge about risk has
had a tremendous success not only in
public health but throughout government
policy
um so this invention of risk clinking
can be seen as an event in thought
anyone recognize my dapper philosopher
here it must not be the 1990s so this is
Michel Foucault who called these stet he
who called these moments of mutation in
systems of knowledge the study of the
genealogy of ideas this technique of
genealogy does not assume that there's a
rational progress or a Tilos in the
development of these kinds of ideas or
that there are hidden interests or
ideologies that shape how new ideas
arise rather they emerge and extend
themselves under fairly contingent
historical circumstances but once they
have solidified they become fairly
automatic and unthought they're even a
kind of trap in approaching a wide range
of problems the task of the genealogist
according to Foucault is to reopen these
ways of thinking for questioning
ok so today just to continue on the
theme of this event and thought of the
development of risk calculation the way
you justify vaccination policy is by
demonstrating quantitatively that the
benefits of vaccination outweigh its
risks this is just a historical chart
showing that back that smallpox risk
declined over time in relationship to
the imposition of compulsory vaccination
but it's actually hard to think of um of
any area of social policy that is not at
least to a certain extent shaped by this
way of calculating risk and managing it
you might think of environmental
regulation of drug testing
infrastructure development urban
planning and so on however in recent
years over the last couple of decades
we've arguably entered a period in which
this mode of calculating future events
is no longer salient for a number of the
threats we collectively face at least in
certain areas
we're faced with the possibility of
catastrophic events that outstrip the
technical hook capacities of risk
management in other words the
probability of these events cannot
necessarily be calculated in part
because in many cases they've never
they've never occurred before and the
potential consequences are so great that
they outstrip our means of mitigating
them so just as an example thinking
about the tsunami in Japan from several
years ago what was the quantitative risk
that a tsunami would fled the Japanese
coast and cause a nuclear meltdown was
it possible when people were thinking
about constructing this power plant to
weigh this wrist risk against the energy
benefits that would be conferred by its
construction one approach to this
situation is to say that we should avoid
taking actions that invite such
catastrophes building nuclear power
plants creating new organisms through
agricultural biotechnology warming the
globe by burning fossil fuels this is
often called the precautionary principle
it says our inability to definitively
calculate future risk should not keep us
from taking proactive intervention to
stop the event from occurring in Europe
it's a relatively common view in areas
of ecological threat things like
genetically modified organisms have been
banned in many countries on the grounds
that we don't yet know how catastrophic
their release might be in the United
States on the other hand on the other
hand this view is often derided by those
who argue that there's no scientific
evidence of the harm caused by
genetically modified organisms but this
raises another question how should
experts public officials authorities
approach a potential event whose
occurrence cannot necessarily be avoided
for example a pandemic of a novel strain
of flu a mass casualty terrorist attack
or a category 5 hurricane striking a
major city one of the lessons for
authorities in the wake of Hurricane
Katrina was not only that we
collectively are not prepared for such a
disaster in the future
but also that citizens expect the
government to demonstrate preparedness
to manage natural disasters and other
catastrophic events competently so many
of you may recall Mike Brown the the
infamous head of FEMA during Hurricane
Katrina who was castigated because he
was a political appointee who had no
qualifications for managing disasters
and what became clear to Bush
administration officials Ana and others
was that that the president and those
around him were going to be held
accountable if another disaster occurred
under their watch and it wasn't a good
response to it so you saw a couple of
weeks later this what I found at the
time a really striking picture of
President George HW Bush with the the
Secretary of Homeland Security at the
time David Chertoff I'm flying to a
military facility the u.s. Northern
Command to track the progress of
Hurricane Rita Rita as it hurtled toward
Texas demonstrating to the public you
know we are getting prepared for this
were watching this we're monitoring this
but another striking thing about this
and some of the discussions of
preparedness that I noticed at the time
was a real analogy made between
preparedness for events like terrorist
attacks and natural disasters and even
what seemed to me a very different kind
of potential future event an avian
influenza pandemic
just a couple of months after the failed
response to Katrina the Bush
administration proposed the the biggest
public health investment in federal
government history a seven billion
dollar plan to prepare for pandemic flu
and it was a it was a bipartisan
initiative there was a very little
political disagreement around it on the
grounds as you see in this quotation
from Senator Kennedy we've been shown to
be to have been unprepared for a prior
disaster we need to get prepared for
this next oncoming one so at this point
I had been looking into I can say more
about this later I've been looking into
the the emerging field of biosecurity
and plans for dealing with emerging
disease and I became curious I hadn't
been thinking about natural disasters
before they became curious where did
this way of thinking about future events
come from what was its history what
techniques were involved in measuring
and improving a condition of
preparedness and I've gradually came to
think of the invention of preparedness
as an event in thought analogous to the
invention of risk thinking in the 19th
century like risk calculation it was the
result of a couldn't of a contingent
development in one area that soon spread
to a range of other problem domains so
let me just quickly tell you about that
history that I gradually came upon some
of you may already know about this
intensive governmental preparedness in
the United States for an impending
emergency began in the area of
mobilization for war a little bit in
preparation for the u.s. entry into
World War one and much more
systematically and intensively in the
late 1930s and early 1940's in
preparation for World War two the idea
behind it was that the entire nation our
economy and our population would soon be
in a total war in such an event it would
be necessary for the government to be
able to rapidly centralize and control
the management all of all the nation's
resources for the purpose of creating an
efficient war machine
from 1956 I'll give you a little bit
more detail in it from a second but the
the point in showing it is that such
planning continued into the Cold War and
part of what government agencies such as
the Office of Defense mobilization were
engaged in was thinking about what would
be the structure of a future emergency
government in the event of a total war
and as you see in this plan the war time
structure of the executive branch the
entire federal government would
radically transform and a single agency
the office of war resources would be in
charge of managing all of the human and
natural resources of the country toward
toward developing in an efficient and
effective industrial mobilization
apparatus this is a kind of close-up of
it but you just see that agencies that
had been called things like the the site
of the Department of Health became war
health administration department of
agriculture the war food administration
and so on so the main point here is just
that there were a lot of mainly hidden
from public view efforts to think about
and prepare for what kind of capacities
would be necessary in the event of a
future nuclear attack so the other
another more famous thing that happened
during that during the Cold War as part
of the history of preparedness was the
adoption of the technique of war games
or simulations from the world of the
military to to public preparedness for a
nuclear attack to simulate what a future
attack would look like and the goal of
this was in part to get citizens
galvanized and ready but also to
generate anticipatory knowledge of what
kinds of vulnerabilities we had in the
present that we were going to need to
address to be ready for this future
nuclear war so for example the federal
civil defense administration learned
where to place these package disaster
hospitals of which we had 2,500 that
were stored in different parts of the
country in relationship to where it was
anticipated the Soviet Union would
strike with its weapons
the famous problem for civil defense was
that as much as the government tried to
get people get citizens to prepare for
it the more and more powerful
thermonuclear bombs became the less
convinced citizens were that techniques
like evacuation plans or bomb shelters
were going to do any good
once this nuclear holocaust occurred so
those broad disillusion among the public
but also eventually among government
officials with the possibilities for
civil defense this is the context in the
early 1960s in which Herman Kahn the
rand mathematician that I mentioned
earlier became famous for his advice to
the public and to government officials
to think about the unthinkable he argued
that the difference between the survival
of some portion of the population in the
wake of a future nuclear catastrophe on
the one hand or the total annihilation
of civilization inherit in whether we
had the courage and imagination today to
plan in detail for our post attack
situation so develop this technique of
scenarios which were not predictions or
forecasts of what was likely to happen
but rather what he thought of as
imaginative devices that could provide
insight into present preparations so
using this technique Khan argued that
bomb shelters should be stocked with
radiation dosimeter z' devices to
measure a individual exposure to
radiation so that in in a contaminated
post-attack environment citizens would
eventually be willing to leave their
bomb shelters and go outside and rebuild
civilizations so just you have to the
idea being just you have to sink very
carefully about what's going to unfold
in the future
but if the system of thinking
preparedness had relied on civil defense
for its long-term sustenance it would
have fallen into decline by the 1960s
and 1970s well as I said the public and
government officials gradually became
disillusioned with the possibility of
preparing for nuclear calamity local
authorities took advantage of federal
civil defense resources to plan for
other kinds of disasters beginning in
the 1960s hurricanes wildfires
earthquakes so you had the founding of a
local offices of emergency management
all around the country and by that by
the 1960s the office of defense
mobilization had become the offices of
emergency planning meanwhile tools that
were initially designed to help in
nuclear preparedness scenario based
exercises or the warning systems
stockpiles of emergency supplies could
now be applied to a range of potential
events but the late 1970s this approach
of emergency management was applied to
still other possible events terrorist
attacks beginning the nineteen the early
seventies ecological accidents such as
nuclear meltdowns in 1979 the Federal
Emergency Management Agency was founded
according to the rubric of what was
called All Hazards preparedness
precisely this idea of preparing for a
range of different kinds of events and
FEMA was folded into the new Department
of Homeland Security in 2002 right after
the attacks of 9/11 okay let me um close
this part of the talk or link us to a
linkage of the conversation period just
with a quick discussion of what happens
when these two ways of thinking about
the future collide come in detention and
I want to use the example of a simulated
bioterrorist attack that initially took
place or that took place in 2001 June of
2001 just before the attacks of 9/11 a
little bit of context over the 1990s
national security officials had been had
become
that the Soviet Union had been
stockpiling huge amounts of weaponized
stop smallpox
during the 1980s in that with the
decline of the Soviet Union these
stockpiles of weaponized smallpox had
scattered her possibly two rogue nations
or terrorist groups and that the u.s.
was woefully unprepared for the
possibility of a smallpox attack they
began to wonder what would happen if the
US was hit with such an attack since
most of the US population did not have
any immunity to smallpox we had stopped
vaccinating we had stopped compulsory
vaccination in the 1960s in 2001 a group
of public official public health experts
and national security officials
collaborated to create a scenario based
exercise a public health war game called
dark winter that simulated a
bioterrorist attack on the US using the
smallpox virus the premise of the
exercise was if we can imaginatively
enact this event we can both learn about
current gaps in response and we can also
convince public officials of the
seriousness of this threat so we can get
some resources devoted to it the results
of the simulation it was a three day
exercise held in Washington DC
the results were dire the disease spread
rapidly it turned out that first
responders were unwilling to help there
were not nearly enough doses of vaccine
in stockpiles to immunize the public
there were not only massive numbers of
casualties from a from the outbreak but
civil unrest and government breakdown
ensued the roll player who is playing
the president in the exercise the former
senator from Georgia
Sam Nunn was especially struck by the
problem of vulnerable first responders
public health workers firemen and so on
who according to the scenario would be
unwilling to respond because they
themselves lacked immunity to smallpox
he and others argued that the US should
immediately establish a policy of what
they called pre event smallpox
vaccination of first respond
that is to immunize millions of Public
Health and emergency workers in advance
of any smallpox attack the only problem
with this program was that taking the
vaccine itself entailed significant
health risks smallpox vaccine is a
weakened version of the smallpox virus
especially for those who are already
immunocompromised there were certain to
be casualties from the government's
vaccination program whether or not an
actual smallpox attack occurred the
committee that advises the Centers for
Disease Control on vaccine policy which
operates according to a rationality of
risk-based calculation refused to make a
recommendation on the proposed program
on the grounds that they could not make
a technical risk assessment because
while the risk of taking the vaccine was
known the risk of a smallpox attack was
not known there was no way to do a
cost-benefit analysis however a year
later after the attacks of 9/11 and the
anthrax letter letters that followed and
in the midst of the lead up to the Iraq
war vice president Cheney's office
charged with thinking about the threat
of bioterrorism was convinced that this
threat was dire and insisted that the
CDC approve the program meanwhile large
numbers of smallpox vaccine doses were
added to the strategic national
stockpile of medical countermeasures you
may know there are several huge
warehouses around the country that
maintain stockpiles of drugs and
vaccines against a set of select
pathogens now this vaccination program
turned out to be a fiasco first
responders were unwilling to volunteer
for the program and it was discontinued
in 2003 after immunizing less than 3% of
the envisioned 10,000,000 vaccinees one
way to think about this is that there
was an in unresolvable tension between
security authorities who are thinking in
terms of preparedness and the health
workers who could only be convinced
through actuarial rationality who did
not see the benefits of taking the
vaccine out weighing the risks but it
also points to a more general problem
that preparedness efforts face since
they must envision
plan for events that may or may not
occur it is typically hard for
preparedness efforts to sustain
attention and galvanize resources so
long as the event does not happen
consider the image of this strategic
national stockpile these warehouses full
of drugs and countermeasures now full of
supplies of smallpox vaccine and Tamiflu
that are expensive to maintain and may
well never be used
moreover the credibility of these
efforts is often undermined when it
turns out that officials have been
preparing for the wrong event we can
talk about this more later about there's
a really interesting story from 2008 in
which the World Health Organization
responded intensively to swine flu based
on the preparations for a different
strain of flu and we're widely
criticized for having overreacted so
with that let's turn to our conversation
thank you very much
all right I'm great
so that last story is so incredible and
as is the stool so so let's let's dive
into that again for for a quick second
so the initial exercise takes place
before 9/11 and then how does the
decision-making you know from the crisis
how does that affect it was it was it
shell was there momentum that this was
being evaluated or did it change after
the event yeah the timeline is really
significant so in June of 2001 this
scenario it's held it's it turns out not
to be initially very effective
the CDC won't approve the program will
recommend the program it looks like
Congress wanted proportion resources for
it but then that fall of course a few
months later 9/11 happens meanwhile
briefings of the simulation are being
circulated around among congressmen and
among members of the executive branch it
becomes more and more effective it
becomes
it's made more plausible of course by
the anthrax attacks that follow so by
2002 when the vice president's office
again says to the CDC take up this
question of whether we should have a
pre-event vaccination program CDC
basically recedes from doing its usual
technical risk assessment admitting that
they can't do it but goes ahead and
approves the program and they bait they
go ahead and introduce that to wide
publicity the smallpox vaccination
program but it's voluntary and it
massively fails yeah it's so I mean one
of the things you you've said is that
what you're studying is our or you say
this mother-to-be but but the but the
how we approach an unknowable future and
it's and that trajectory from the
auricle through to these things and it
seems like when you get to that point
with these first responders there's
another form of future prediction which
is a lottery essentially some percentage
of these people are going
it's no longer just a a statistic in an
actuary table now it's it's real human
lives even a small percentage so so it's
a remarkable thing yeah it's actually
freaking us out yeah include the moments
actually critical here is that the the
vaccination program was voluntary or
something if they had forced the entire
population of smallpox I'm sorry of
health workers to take the vaccine then
you would have got a very different
result and that individual subjective
sets of risk wouldn't have mattered as
much so say something more about how
these ways of thinking about planning
for the future anticipating how it
shapes may be narrow that it shapes the
possibilities of how the future may play
out or otherwise shapes the the future
cuz I know that's one of things here
you're interested yeah I think the way I
like to think about is that you know a
given event occurs and it can be taken
up in a variety of ways you might think
about the the possibility of a hurricane
make it be thought of in terms of the
strength of levees in terms of the
vulnerability of certain social groups
for those who live in poor areas each of
those ways of thinking about about the
threat implies different kinds of
interventions if you think about the
threat in terms of preparedness there
are a specific set of tools that you put
into place these exercises evacuation
plans and so on it's not to say that one
shouldn't but one should certainly be
aware of the decision the ones making
about which style of reasoning you're
going to apply to the threat mm-hmm and
and it and it seems like tell me if I'm
summarizing this right but it's like the
the preparation thing a lot of it comes
from that World War two mobilization the
duck-and-cover and and other things and
and then it but then it comes to
bureaucratic so the implementation of
bureaucrats using a military kind of
strategy and thinking is there's maybe
one place where there starts to be a
problem is that very same yeah well you
know
I want to insist that I'm not condemning
the spread of preparedness indeed it's
essential and as we saw after Hurricane
Katrina was - it was really a
governmental pathology not to it to have
appointed somebody incapable of doing
preparedness to the head of his agency
charged with it yeah so so by showing
that its history is contingent and then
it has a set of assumptions it's not to
say that it's it's bad or not worth
doing but rather that it takes us in
certain directions and potentially not
in others and also to point to some of
its problems it preparedness has to make
some decisions about which things it's
going to prepare for is it going to be a
smallpox attack is it going to be avian
influenza is it going to be climate
change and so on we have a limited
amount of resources for events that may
or may not happen so you're focused on
how experts in particular and and this
is authorities they're there but it but
it's and it's going back to the Oracle
and in the earliest it seems like
throughout all there's there's because
because we're by and large here not the
experts but we're certainly aware of
future uncertainties it's something
that's it's very on everyone's minds
right now and it seems like you know in
each of those models there's kind of the
there's the expert and there's their
audience whether it's someone going to
the Oracle to ask them something about
the future or whether it's the
population of the u.s. being critical of
the Bush administration's handling of
Treena etc so and so same thing about
that and then maybe we'll talk about the
h1n1 story because that's that's
something that I think has a sort of
cycle of I don't know is that and how I
guess with with the focus of your study
what do we as people in the population
what can we learn from hearing more
about how experts are handling these
things I mean I think you know probably
in this audience everybody's an expert
in something right and when I mean
what's interesting about expertise
living in it in a knowledge society is
that
you know it's not that that we as a
collective leave everything to the
experts but that we've kind of divided
up the world of social problems into
specific kinds of expertise and there's
certain people who are authorized to
speak about each of those so as audience
members you know what we were typically
we're going to rely on folks from the
CDC for example to tell us which help
public health less risks are the most
worrisome ones um and I don't I don't
necessarily criticize that I think I do
think we should become we should be more
aware of how those decisions are made
and what kinds of assumptions underlie
underlie those for the purposes of
critical analysis really so so why don't
we talk about the h1n1 story and we're
gonna have mics around so be thinking
about your questions we'd love to get
some good dialogue going and hear what
you wanted to dig into more but so so
talking about this 2008 situations sure
so just to kind of take the story
forward from smallpox some of you may
recall the event of the SARS outbreak in
2002 that this really alerted global
health officials to the idea that there
were these possible emerging pathogens
that were untreatable that were not yet
known and that could be really
devastating not only caused lots of
illnesses but massive economic damage as
well rent rent right around that time a
new strain of avian flu was circulating
an avian flu the issue of avian flu is
that if you get it you're actually very
likely to die from it it has about a 50
or 60 percent case fatality rate the
fortunate thing is you're only going to
get it if you are very affectionate with
a chicken meant that or a fowl that has
as they affectionately you know in close
proximity so so the real fear that
public health experts had over in in the
period around 2004 2005 and onward was
that flu which which which mutates quite
easily especially in these reservoirs in
which ducks and chickens and humans are
living in close proximity would reassert
as Li transmissible the way that
seasonal flu is
among humans and if it maintained
anything close to that kind of case
fatality rate remember that the 1918 flu
had it something like a 2% of case
fatality rate and we're talking about
50% this is gonna be a massive
catastrophe probably one of the greatest
in the human history so all that's to
say global health officials were on
vigilant alert using these tools of
preparedness we've been talking about
scenario based exercises stockpiling
Tamiflu developing Sentinel devices to
track the onset of possible humanely
transmissible flu suddenly in early 2008
reports came from Mexico surprisingly
since they thought it was going to come
from Asia of a new respiratory illness
those killing people at high rates the
existing preparedness measures were very
quickly triggered countries in Europe
and in the end the United States had
developed national mass vaccination
campaigns and when you say triggered
there's - tell us how how that so all
these the wealthy countries had
developed pandemic preparedness plans
that involve things like mass
vaccination programs so that they've
even reserved enough vaccine for their
populations because of course these had
to be reduce rapidly once the strain was
known they produced enough vaccines for
their for their populations so that in
the event of the detection of an
outbreak that could rapidly put into
motion this vaccination campaign so that
was done at by June within within a
couple of months that was done by July
or August it was actually known
epidemiologically that the case fatality
rate was not so serious
this was swine flu this was not hmm h5n1
so is those so in other words they've
been preparing for the wrong kind of flu
in Europe countries that spend billions
of euros on these vaccinations programs
and five or ten only five or 10% of the
population at best was taking the
vaccine so it all went to waste and
pretty soon that the World Health
Organization was accused of conflict of
interest they were accused of being in
cahoots with the pharmaceutical industry
for having over having exaggerated the
threat sounded a false alarm and I think
that that was a red herring really what
happened was that
we're kind of trapped by the very system
of thinking about the future that
they've put into place in response to a
different threat and then there's
together the next bit that there's a
sure that that sort of moves on and
there's they adjust there but with that
with that negative feedback from the
audience as it were from the public they
adjust those things and by the way
there's Julie with the the mic she's
gonna hold them up so if you want to get
a question let's get her attention show
house yeah so I mean the next the next
piece of the story and we can go from
there to zico or anywhere else from
there but the next piece of the story is
of course the an event that wasn't being
prepared for which was an Ebola epidemic
in West Africa which turned into a
global health calamity in 2014 and the
global health authorities had not been
on alert for that there were no
stockpiles of people of Ebola vaccine in
place and that World Health Organization
was blamed for spending a lot of time
ignoring the outbreak in the inset of
the first several months in 2014 when it
was spreading in West Africa for quite
that the reaction was quite different
from the reaction to h1n1 had six years
beforehand precisely because they hadn't
thought that Ebola was going to be the
kind of problem that it became great oh
there we go it seems to me like there's
kind of a conundrum here I mean in in
terms of Public Health you have to trust
the experts but in in Katrina as I
recall the Army Corps of Engineers when
they designed and built the levees used
a category 4 hurricane as their case
knowing full well that the hundred year
storm was a category 5 earthquake and
that saving 75 million dollars on
construction costs would ultimately be a
disaster on the other hand you know the
vac sirs don't trust the experts
to our risk so it seems to me that there
needs to be a protocol and a dialogue
about and have these choices be made on
a more open basis so that people can
confirm the assumptions that are made so
is expert knowledge I mean should we
trust expert knowledge and and is the
public perception you know how how does
that weigh in as an expert or as a check
or as a what do you think you know just
I'll stick with this case of the Army
Corps of Engineers just to take to take
that one I mean that's of course the
case of what I was calling actuarial
reason so you have risk and and there's
an interesting distinction made between
risk calculation and risk management and
this calculation is something that we
kind of leave to the technical experts
what is the probability of a category
four or a category 5 hurricane striking
striking new orleans based on the
historical record you might be able to
make this kind of calculation what's
called risk management is typically
thought of as a more political decision
exactly how much money should we spend
on preparedness should we be preparing
for a category 5 or a category 4
hurricane so that's in a sense the place
at which at least in principle we need
to open up the process as you say and
say okay well yes we realize that you
have some actual actuarial knowledge in
the Army Corps of Engineers over how to
calculate risk and how how to construct
Elevens in relationship to that risk but
we want to know what exactly are you
preparing for and and what kind of
political decision are you making when
you do that we've got next question here
and then because one in the back too oh
great so
in terms of preparedness you know we
have we have a lot of different
organizations that are trying to prepare
in different ways
earlier I was talking with someone about
seed ball of Pennsylvania are grants it
yeah that's a she was always hard but
yeah so like we have things like that
then then there's this whole concern
about economical economic crises around
currencies deflating rat payee or Frank
banks collapsing things like that and so
there's just talk about decentralizing
things that way they've become more
abundant more secure you know with that
thought process and then kind of you're
talking about you know how we have this
projection into the future
have you seen folks in your studies have
those thought exercises of well how
should we be thinking about this instead
you know as things evolve within our
yeah one of the major developments that
I think relates to what you're talking
about is that what we might call the
work on resilience sososo resilience of
the idea that you know we're necessarily
going to be susceptible to shocks that
are not necessarily predictable and the
task is to make us more able to
withstand they bounce back from their
shows and those are that that's not
really in commensurable with the ideas
of preparedness some of the ideas of
preparedness that I've talked about but
it it becomes more sophisticated because
it asks okay so what is it about social
relations for example or was it that
what is it about financial organisations
that might make them more resilient just
to shock and as you're suggesting you
know one argument has been that
distributed bottom-up kinds of
structures are more likely you know as
at the community level for example are
more likely to be able to deal with at
least certain kinds of disasters than
top-down centralized command structures
you one might think about the example of
the invention of the internet at some
memo so you probably know it was funded
by DARPA and and the idea was to create
a communication system that would be
resilient against nuclear attack by not
having any single single node that could
be taken down and that's why it's a
distributed structure of communication
that's in this network form so you know
thinking about resilience has been you
know part of preparedness since since
the 1950s but I think that with you know
as we get to thinking more about whether
it's disease threats or climate change
or financial crisis this discourse of
resilience has become one more
significant so as we get our next
question the audience ready there's
there's this so the Internet's a great
example of something that had one
intention and had an amazing use that
was completely different so so I wonder
a bit about it and I can't help but
reflect on all these Cold War
preparations as extensive preparations
lots of time energy money went into
doing these things they weren't really
tested they weren't really we don't
really have by and large an evaluation
of how well they work is there a sense
of evaluation and reflection that's
happening for these systems as they've
been built for these tools whether they
have an actual like the some of the
disease ones we've talked about they
actually happen or if they're just sort
of there and are drilled or
what-have-you which what's the history
of that and is there progress that's
happening there or is it the opposite of
progress yeah I mean one of the things I
got fascinated with from the outset of
this research was the question of how
you measure whether in fact you're
prepared for something that has never
occurred it may not ever occur and this
is where I thought that you know the
history of these scenario-based
exercises is really quite interesting
because in fact beginning in the early
1950s
the federal government used these
exercises precisely to try to test
itself to try to figure out okay you
know if we if we imagine that the Soviet
Union is gonna hit us in these places
what's going to happen are we ready
of course fortunately we never found out
whether we were ready answer would have
been no right but it's it's it's worth
pointing out that the answer actually in
these acts
is always know and it's purposely no you
know part of the point it exercises is
to tell you you're not prepared both to
get you a little bit more worried and to
in fact find out the the sites where you
need to intervene when the public health
story which is the story I know most
about is interesting in that after each
one of these events SARS well less so
SARS but certainly h1n1 Ebola now Zika
there are systems in place for doing
retrospective evaluation of the
emergency response that are designed to
try to instigate reforms to the
institution so in some ways part of the
preparedness evaluation so that part of
the preparedness system are these
techniques of post hoc assessment and
those seem to be happening and and
beneficial in in the in what you're
seeing or well you know beneficial will
depend on what happens next I mean we
don't know but it but I don't know thing
that's gonna happen acts yes so we know
you know just to take the health example
one of the post hoc recommendations
after the Ebola epidemic was that world
health agencies of philanthropic
organizations need to be spending more
money building public health capacity in
poor countries not for the sake of the
health of the people in these poor
countries but for the sake of our health
because if we want to detect and contain
one of these novel viruses before it
gets to us we better be able to do it in
the place where it happens now you could
certainly say that's a good thing in
that in that you know these are places
where there's been the public health
infrastructure has been left to declare
decay but if you look at what's actually
being planned to be put in place it's a
very specific kind of public health
infrastructure it's going to detect a
novel and emerging disease when in fact
arguably what's most needed in many of
its places is very basic preventive care
yeah treating diarrhea in infants
so so you may end up missing the real
problem because your focus is going to
be on protection of the self and that's
one of these examples are talking about
of shaping the future because you've
you've created a detection mechanism or
a it
a capacity that's only for these very
specialized things and missed lots of
lots of blind spots they benefit okay
next yeah okay pretty sure to hold it
close dear thank you for a very
interesting talk
and like many 20 minute presentations I
have a lot of questions afterwards
particularly around your title of how we
became quotes unprepared and maybe it's
cuz worth the long now but I'm thinking
like on a ten thousand years scale we're
pretty we're more prepared than we've
ever been and I might be missing the
humor behind your quotes here but my my
question is kind of what's the future of
preparedness is big data going to make
us better at being prepared and I'd love
it if you can tie in any anecdotes of
being most underprepared over-prepared
like I think of things like y2k and
stuff like that that had us all you know
Mayan calendars ending which I was not
concerned about but other people were
mm-hmm so it seems there's a struggle
between being most underprepared and
over prepared and learning to prepare
better so what's the future right I mean
I'll a instead of working on this for 10
years there's been a series of disasters
and they turn out never to be the ones
that we were thinking about in advance
not to say that they won't happen but
but indeed this problem of fine-tuning
preparedness so that actually deals with
the problem that's going to hit turns
out to be paradoxically quite difficult
there's also a way in which said so on
the on the other hand there are events
now like anthropogenic climate change
for which we could be pretty confident
that those those catastrophes are
heading our way
and indeed we can make the argument that
we need resilience for preparedness
measures for it so that's one feature of
preparedness these are the my title
yeah I mean so it kind of fits with this
the quotation that came afterwards which
is the kind of you know we're overdue
and we're underprepared and that the
idea that you you know we hear this all
the time and and I completely agree with
that point you make indeed we are much
more prepared than we were fifty years
ago because the very idea that we should
become prepared was invented roughly
fifty years ago so I'm interested in
that invention that is what I mean by
how we became unprepared you know not
not to say that we were once
well-prepared and now we're less so but
rather we and you know not everybody but
men you know experts in authorities and
many in many arenas think of us think of
ourselves as unprepared and that's the
that's the story I want to tell and then
we'll take one more question but but let
me get a couple of quick questions in
here about so we have the limb magazine
in the back tell us something about that
and tell us both about the book that's
coming up this is from your book cover
that's coming out in August right and
that's about the subject that's focused
on the health preparedness you write
actually it actually fits into your
question so the title of the book is
called it's called unprepared global
health at the time of emergency and this
is the the image on the cover and and my
friends like to tease me that it's a
no-shit book like we should be putting
on our suits something nasty is coming
down the pike and of course it's not
because it's basically saying well let's
step back and ask ourselves why we're
saying we should not to say that we
shouldn't be worried I'm just in any
case so that's that's the book that's
coming out in August and then the
magazine which there are some copies
there couple guy was the first and third
yeah so your and your co-editor avoided
or of alcalá de the academic scene those
of us in you know in in in the obscure
realms of academia sometimes try to
think about how we might communicate to
to a broader public and so we we came up
with this idea of commissioning people
that we think have something smart to
say about a contemporary problem that we
think
perhaps is not being well reflected on
in the public sphere or that there could
be other that there are ways of thinking
more critically about it and also we
Commission people whose books usually
take 10 years who know him a tremendous
amount of in something we say listen
give us an article that's only 2,000
words a roughly op-ed length a little
longer give it to us in six weeks we'll
publish it we turn these around very
quickly they've been a number of issues
we're now on our eighth issue which is
called hacks leaks and breaches about
cybersecurity and you know contemporary
debates around how to deal with you know
with with leaks but we've had issues on
centinall devices which I talked about
today we had an issue about the Ebola
epidemic an issue on systemic risk so so
I encourage you to look at we have a
print version and an online version that
they online this version is Li M and I T
okay let's stop there okay
one last question in the back and it's
going to get a couple of them I'll
answer both the last two I think I think
yeah I think we'll this will be the last
one but then you're gonna stick around
and so we know there are a lot more
questions so but great thank you very
much super interesting I totally
appreciate your system view on this a
couple observations and a couple
questions first is your preparedness is
so difficult to measure
compared to response I mean response we
can measure response times we can
measure response resources we can reach
we can talk about mean time to repair
things that is nature but it's difficult
to measure preparedness second let's not
let a good crisis go to waste right so
then we have these crisis over and over
again so that that use of after-action
reviews is a great way to learn and turn
these into learning opportunities rather
than simply response or things but I
would ask you in your work becomes
you're riffing off so many other
questions and that is we live in
California we live in an all hazard
all-risk place
I mean we're sitting literally on
landfill right now right like right now
unreinforced major is going but
and we live in the earthquakes and we
have all kinds of other things and so
that idea of expert and audience so with
the experts say that as individuals we
should be prepared and take up to 72
hours and so then why don't people do it
like like what does good look like and
what does great look like and I'm
wondering if you've seen best practices
from anywhere else because it seems like
people will take some amount of
awareness they'll get some education and
they'll take a little bit of action but
then if we need it evacuate San
Francisco or on a large wildland fire
they happen literally every year
thousands of times a year in California
well how do we overcome the human
behavior part of this well this is we're
gonna sit back at Sam a cultural
anthropologist but I just want to
accentuate a couple of points you made
and agree with them and one of the from
the Cold War on from civil defense on
authorities who who realized that in
fact you know for this system to work we
need the public to do what it's supposed
to do have been wringing their hands or
the difficulty of getting them to do it
and part of it has to do with attention
part of it has to do with multiple
possible threats part of it hasn't do it
the sense that there's so great that
individuals don't know what to do we and
we have this interesting culture now as
we haven't talked about it yet the
Doomsday Preppers people you know people
in Silicon Valley buying ireland's in
the South Pacific and or and so on so so
there are certain instantiations of
particular people who decide they're
gonna they're gonna do it but indeed
repeatedly we've found that you know
it's very hard to get the public to to
to engage in preparedness and I think
you know the standard reasons given are
that they've public feels helpless so
one thing to do with as I risk
communication specialist is to really
explain what they can do I'll close with
one one interesting anecdote that that I
think somewhat encapsulates this the
field of risk communication I think is a
really interesting one and it developed
as part of the school the system that
I've been talking about today and and
after
as h1n1 was that business swine flu back
in 2008 was beginning to spread or 2009
I guess just spread around the country
it was clear that you know there wasn't
a lot that people could do yet that
vaccines weren't available but public
health officials were we're told to get
up and tell people things to do wash
your hands a lot probably if each one
and one had been really deadly washing
their hands a lot wasn't couldn't help
but there was a sense that you know the
public needs to have us have a role in
order to take in order to trust and take
seriously the the arguments being made
by officials so so this field of this
communication has been thinking
precisely about that all right well we
have to end it there but so a big round
of applause for
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]